It wasn't just digital de-aging that made
Harrison Ford look forty years younger in
the opening of "Indiana Jones and the Dial of
Destiny" — crew members also made a special mask
that lives firmly in the uncanny valley. Stick
around for a closer look at this creepy creation.
Prior to the release of "Indiana Jones and
the Dial of Destiny," there was a lot of
talk about how the film would use de-aging
technology for the sequence at the beginning
of the film set during World War II. The goal
was to make Indiana Jones look similar to how
he did in "Raiders of the Lost Ark," and
the digital effect was mostly a success.
While there's ample CGI on display throughout
the rest of the movie, there are also good,
old-fashioned practical effects — including a
realistic mask that may just haunt your dreams.
On Instagram, special effects artist Waldo Mason
shared images of a stunt mask used in "Dial of
Destiny." While the realistic skin texture
makes the mask somewhat uncanny on its own,
it doesn't seem all that freaky — but it's a
different story when we see it in action. Mason
included two pictures of a stunt double wearing
the mask atop a motorcycle and standing in an
office. The use of stunt doubles with prosthetics
is nothing new for action movies — but out of
context, the mask is definitely getting a
strong reaction from Indiana Jones fans.
There's been no shortage of pop culture
similarities pointed out on social media.
Several people compared it to Michael
Myers' mask from the "Halloween" movies,
and one Twitter user even wrote —
"[It] definitely looks like
something from Dawn of the Dead."
Other comparisons included the
realistic disguises of the "Mission:
Impossible" franchise and the mask that Ryan
Gosling wears at one point in "Drive." However,
the most common reference seems to have been
to the "Prank Show" sketch from Netflix's "I
Think You Should Leave," which depicts
star Tim Robinson covered in so many
prosthetics that he loses his cool in a
shopping mall. Many fans of the show were
quick to point out the Indiana Jones mask's
resemblance to the troublemaker Karl Havoc.
"I'm not doing it… I don't even
want to be around anymore."
Despite all the jokes, some film
enthusiasts pointed out that they
were happy to see practical effects being
used in 2023. Another Twitter user stated —
"Long proud history of these in
movies. I'll take these over CGI any
day because at least the brain knows
there's a real person in the shot."
It's great to see stunt performers
continuing to get work in movies of
this scale — even if Harrison Ford thinks
they could back off every now and then.
Stuntmen and stuntwomen play
crucial roles on film sets:
they often do the difficult scenes an actor
can't risk doing, as an injury would shut
down production. With Harrison Ford being
an octogenarian, there's little doubt that
stunt performers were needed occasionally
to help with some of his scenes. However,
Ford still did plenty on his own and even thought
the stunt workers were sometimes doing too much.
When speaking with Esquire, Ford
discussed one scene in which he
thought too many people were trying to help
him off of a horse. As he described it —
"I look down and there's three stunt
guys there making sure I [don’t] fall
off the stirrup. They said, 'Oh, we
were just afraid because we thought,
you know,' and bah bah bah bah. And I said,
'Leave me the f— alone, I'm an old man.'"
Ford also said that he wanted to actually look
like an older man getting off a horse — after all,
Indy's advanced age is a pretty important
part of his story in "Dial of Destiny."
A lot of hard work goes into making a movie.
Someone needs to make a convincing Harrison
Ford mask, someone else needs to wear that
mask, a third person has to shoot it in action,
and a whole team of people have to fix any present
issues in post. It's all for the greater good of
bringing a story to the big screen, even if
the mask looks so hot and uncomfortable that
the person wearing it would probably want to
rip it off while having an existential crisis.